what would you recommend to a
screenwriter who doesn't have an agent
manager or producer to guide them so yep
I guess presuming that they're sort of
up-and-coming you know I think getting
an agent or a manager not both when
you're starting off is a good Avenue
because you really need an advocate I
mean a lot of writers are not
necessarily good at pitching themselves
and and even if you are there's
something that just comes off
pretentious and arrogant about talking
about how great your own work is I mean
that's good you do the writing let them
do the talking
you know and so I do think a good agent
or manager I just don't think your
career is big enough even big writers
don't often need both but just an
advocate to go out and push for you is
is I think is always worthwhile so
assume you don't know anybody I think a
good way to try to get to an agent it
matters there's a few good ways number
one is you know networking obviously but
not necessarily directly with agents and
managers a lot of times you can as you
get to know more people in this industry
whether it's producers DPS actors
whoever you start meeting other people
who are represented and a good way to
get in with agents and managers even
better than just meeting them at the
party and saying hey look I'm a writer
you know can you take a look at my stuff
is knowing someone who already knows
them is oftentimes a better way to do it
so instead of going out trying to be an
agent or manager look at your own
resource base and other people you know
it's like my friends wrapped by
innovative artists maybe you know hey
I'll take you out to dinner you just get
can you get me you know get my script
over there get somebody to look at it or
get me a meeting I'll take you out for a
nice dinner or whatever but leverage
your own contacts because this is a
relationship business so even more than
being able to just go up to an agent and
say I know you don't know me but I'd
really like to take a look at my stuff
they usually don't but if it comes from
someone they already know and trust
that's a good way to get so look at like
who you and that that's what I've
advised I have a friend of mine director
who he's he's a visual effects guy his
name's Lloyd Barnett he's an amazing
visual effects guy he was a lead
compositor on Avatar and he directed a
movie I produced called ninja apocalypse
he also do a lot of visual effects in
that movie and he wants a direct he
wants do more directing so I
don't put together director real and
he's asking God you know how do I get to
these agents I'm like it no it's
business a long time you have to know
people that have agents yeah I'm like
think about you know other POV effects
artists you've worked with think about
you know other you know below the line
that you've worked with composers you
have a friend he does music he might be
repped by this age you know he's yeah
he's ripped by Gersh you know talk to
him great see if he can get you uh get
your you know your real looked at so
that's one way I think I think another
way to is you know talent rises to the
top I do believe that I do believe that
talent will eventually be rewarded real
talent
I'm fortunately I think a lot of people
have an over overestimate their own
abilities a lot so you I think you know
you being being recognized as as
talented it's gotta be someone else
other than yourself just saying it other
other people need to recognize the
talent that that's what sort of hmm I
think that's what make that's what I
would say actually elevates you to the
point of when when you have other people
in the industry who have some amount of
modicum of success I think this guy's
talented I think that's that's when it's
legitimate it's great that you believe
in yourself having confidence is
fantastic I think the whole self-esteem
movement has done more to harm young
kids then help them self-esteem is
something where you know you believe
that you are owed something that you
should feel good just because you're
unique and you're this and you're that
as opposed to you know having
accomplished something and I feel like
as opposed to confidence is a different
thing believing you can go out and get
it as opposed to self-esteem believing
that you're great and you're owed
something just because you're unique I
don't buy that but I believe that you
should be confident you know in your in
your abilities to a you know to a degree
not overconfident but be confident in
yourself that either that you have some
autumn Kumada come of talent or that you
can develop the town you have into a
skill and I so I think that some people
that are good to judge to judge that is
some of the screenplay competitions some
of the better ones like and I had to
bring the whole article on this at funds
for writers calm I wrote a whole article
on the pros
screenplay competitions but some of the
top ones like the Sundance screenwriters
lab like the Nicholls Austin blue cat
tracking the final drafts big break
there's a few that and I think they've
elevated themselves because they've been
around for a long time and they use a
lot of industry working industry
professionals to read the scripts and
grade them so you have people that are
in the industry that are in the know
they're not just hiring interns or kids
I can't read this and do coverage on it
but it's they have experienced readers
and when you have enough of those
competitions saying you know I think
this this guy has got something or you
know this script is really is something
else it's a fresh voice what have you
you know I think there then there's some
legitimacy to okay this person really
does have some talent because you have
some experience third parties who have
an eye for talent this is what we do as
producers as directors right we like we
identify talent you know and I think if
you can excel in some of those
competitions you're gonna get you know
hot the opportunities to interface with
agents and managers if you can at least
hit in a big computation competition the
quarter-final level you can you can get
I think you can get agents and managers
to read your script if you can get to
the semi-final they'll probably be
calling you and if you get the finals
level you're gonna get meetings you know
if you're a finalist in Nichols
you're gonna have you're gonna you will
be able to get meetings with William
Morris and CAA because that's such a
limited pool of people compared to the
number that apply I mean literally
thousands and thousands of people apply
and it gets down to literally a small
handful of people so I think that's
another way to get to you know to get to
agents managers so play out you're your
own resource base and see who you know
that's that's already wrapped and see if
you can get in that way and also
competitions I think that's two ways to
get to to get access to agents and
managers
you